millions of households are really facing
a cost of living crisis at the moment
and we're doing everything we can to
keep our prices as low as we can one of
the things you can see in our results
today is that we're inflating behind the
market and look day in day out we're
working really hard to keep our prices
as low as we possibly can because that's
what our customers need us to do of
course there's inflation in energy and
the cost of living and food prices has
gone up customers are watching every
penny and every pound and you know what
we're doing is doing everything we can
across our company to put as much into
our own prices as we can and that's why
we're inflating behind the market prices
at Sainsbury's are going up slower than
anywhere else at the moment now you've
said that uh you by the end of March
next year you will have invested 500
million pounds in in price Cuts what are
you looking at beyond that
the value for money is going to be
critically important for customers you
know for the medium to long term and so
that's the reason when we launched our
new plan back in November 2020 that
we've been so focused on being more
competitive and so this isn't an issue
just for the here and now this is about
presenting the best value we can to our
customers on thousands of products every
day and so the progress we've been
making has been very much you know
determined to make sure that on those
things that we all buy every day and
every week the products we put in our
baskets most frequently is where we're
putting all of this value investment as
you say 500 million pounds up until
March next year and we are specifically
focused in areas like our Sainsbury's
quality Aldi price match
um lots of those products are the things
like fruit and vegetables and needs and
poultry and dairy products that we buy
we all buy every week and we are as
competitive as we've ever been there and
we are you know very focused here on
making sure we in what we can to bring
prices down we have a lot of our
products in what we call a price lock
and we've just put 20 percent more
products into our price lock and these
are things that we all buy to put in our
cupboards every week you know cereals
and packaged goods and household
products and what we're seeing is
customers moving more and more into
buying own brand because of course they
can you know get the products they want
to buy but often they're substantially
lower prices than the Branded products
what kind of assumptions are you making
on the future trajectory of food price
inflation where do you see it peaking
well of course there's a lot of pressure
in the system we can we can all see that
and we're hearing about it aren't we you
know the cost of reducing Goods the cost
of energy to make the food that we that
we buy and eat every day the cost of
Labor and the cost of a lot of the raw
materials and ingredients so there's
there's more pressure in the system on
inflation as we look ahead I think which
is why we're so focused that Sainsbury's
in making sure we keep our prices as low
as we possibly can and particularly at
this time of year of course there's
people are thinking ahead to the
Christmas period Everyone's Watching
every penny and every pound at the
moment and so as there's pressure on
inflation that's the reason why we're
battling so hard to make sure that we
keep prices as low as we can I think
you've said today that uh some consumers
are actually spreading their their
Christmas purchases they're already
buying ahead of Christmas now for all
the obvious reasons all of us are
looking to spread the cost of Christmas
aren't we and we saw you know earlier in
the Autumn customers starting plan ahead
for Christmas we've seen you know at the
end of the month when the paychecks have
been coming in people have been thinking
ahead for Christmas and that's meant I
think that customers are really
thoughtful about what they might want to
be by now uh maybe ahead of when they
would normally have done it but of
course you know we've got seven to eight
weeks um seven weeks to Christmas now
and you know I think we're yet to see
how consumer spending patterns will
really pan out this Christmas you know I
think budgets are very tough as we know
the millions of households and so it's
really this month we'll see to what
extent customers are going to really
pull back their spending this year now
Argos has just reported its first sales
growth in the quarter for more than a
year how concerned are you about ongoing
supply chain issues in GM Supply chains
have been challenged over a long period
of time and actually through this period
you know retailers more generally have
had to become very agile in how they
thought and planned so make sure we have
products in stock and so you know now
general merchandise business in office
specifically we're encouraged with the
performance we've had so far this year
we saw sales up in the second quarter
and that's as customers bought new
products for outdoor for the holiday
period given the good weather in the
summer and as we look ahead towards
Christmas and we've been doing a lot of
planning to make sure we've got the
products that customers want to buy they
will always inevitably be supply chain
challenges but in the main I think we're
in a good place for this Christmas with
a World Cup included just before
Christmas this year for the first time
so that will bring a different you know
set of
um challenges into the mix the week
before Christmas as everyone plans for
those occasions but we think we're in
good shape and the most important thing
that we're thinking about every day is
how do we keep our prices as low as we
possibly can for customers and how do we
make sure as we go into Christmas that
we've got good availability of
everything that people want to buy you
mentioned the World Cup though I mean
this is a real challenge for you isn't
it how do you how are you going to get
consumers to will switch their mindset
from buying in beer and pizzas one
moment to sort of Christmas decorations
the next
I think you make a you make a really
good point it's happening in such close
succession isn't it in terms of World
Cup into Christmas obviously depending
how much progress we make through the
World Cup itself it's going to be very
close indeed I think with the you know
the Sunday before Christmas uh
potentially the final so look I think um
it's it's very much on our mind we've
been planning for it for a long period
of time and you know I think what we're
going to see through you know to the
rest of the Autumn and into winter is
that customers are going to spend more
time at home
um you know so I think in many ways
we'll see the World Cup we think being
more of a home occasion uh Captain we
would see in the summer
um we're going to have lots of great
products and lots of great value for
family and friends wanting to get
together to enjoy the match and we'll be
making sure we do the best job for
customers as they prepare for that and
then straight into Christmas as you say
and of course in the last few days to
Christmas always the busiest
um and so that we've got fantastic
colleagues and teams across our business
preparing for this at the moment to make
sure all that we don't let customers
down and we give them everything that
they want